list Seibert shamed me for taking antidepressants
and yes we need to talk about it [Music]
hey everyone it's time to get super vulnerable
and real here in my bed but I wanted to talk
about what happened a few months ago with Liz
and I and also place it into the context of
the broader conversation around mental health
stigma we are actually days away from Mental
Health Awareness Day on October 10th and this
is really a topic that is near and dear to my
heart because I've got a long history of mental
health struggles so a little bit of a back story
I suffer from anxiety basically from childhood
for really as long as I can remember my mom
has told me all these stories about me being so
nervous before like doing a dance competition or
recital that I just would not sleep and this was
like when I was seven and back then most parents
wouldn't have even thought to seek help or get
a diagnosis or really do anything about it so it
actually wasn't until my late teens that I saw
my first therapist and actually it wasn't even
for my underlying long-standing undiagnosed
anxiety disorder it was because I had an Ian
disorder orthorexia that I had developed which of
course had severe kind of anxious undertones but
yeah following my enus order recovery I would
say I struggled with pretty severe generalized
anxiety throughout my 20s and then in my 30s I
was diagnosed with insomnia when I was undergoing
fertility treatments and IVF and you know it just
kind of felt like I was desperately hopeless in
my desire to have tough kids and then this year
I was diagnosed with ocpd or obsessive-compulsive
personality disorder AKA extreme perfectionism
and also ADHD so that's a lot and I've been
really transparent and vulnerable in Sharing all
of this even though I definitely know that some
people will automatically now see me as less than
or sick or incapable of doing you know amazing
things with my life Etc but I really shared these
things in hopes of destigmatizing mental health
diagnosis and also offering some insight into
some of the ways that I've actively were work
to improve my health and life and you know one
of the most profound ways that I've done this is
through medication so I resisted medication up
until like last year that's 34 years of severe
suffering largely because I was you know afraid
of the stigma or the pill shaming that often
comes alongside taking psychiatric medication so
you know often stigmatized is like crazy pills or
addictive toxins you know all of these kinds of
antidepressants and other mood stabilizers have
really long been assigned a really bad rap and
not surprisingly that reputation has often been
transferred to those who take them in Wellness
culture there's this like common idea that folks
who take pills just like didn't do the work and
while I really do not think there's anything
wrong with medication being a first step for many
people's Journeys for me at least that could not
be further from the truth I have been a therapy
consistently for over 20 years so I experimented
with a y wide range of modalities including
CBT cbti DBT EMDR hypnotherapy mindfulness
Etc I also have a very well balanced you know
like a brain supporting diet with little alcohol
and zero recreational substances and I exercise
and meditate daily me taking medications hasn't
been a reason for me to stop all of these mental
health supporting strategies that I've adopted
over the years but rather medication has really
just allowed all of these strategies to actually
take hold so for example I was never able to
meditate before I started medicating because
basically my body and my brain just would never
relax and now I can successfully quiet my mind for
a good 10 minutes of the day so that's progress
to me but anyway mental health medications got me
my life back and if I had only one regret it was
not having the courage to start them earlier which
brings me to the time that Liz Siebert pill shamed
me for using a medication that quite literally
saved my life let me show you how I eat all of
my food within three to four hours every day this
is a really really bad idea hi Abby I'm Liz I'm
the girl in the video that you just reacted to I
actually used to be a fan of yours I used to watch
all of your videos on YouTube but once I really
decided that I was going to get serious about my
health mental and physical I had to stop watching
your videos for a couple of reasons you started
posting videos like this talk very openly about
your use of antidepressants and your dependence
on pharmaceutical drugs just to sleep and get
through the day I was in that exact same spot when
you started posting those videos it was clear to
me that you were stuck in the same place that
I was stuck in so for that reason I decided to
stop watching your videos and stop taking your
advice like I'm honestly still so shocked that
someone thought it was a good idea to post that
and you know I'm clearly not the only one who
has taken aback judging by the comment section
and the countless response stitches that I have
seen on that app but here's the thing I am well
versed and well prepared for Creator retaliation
and criticism I know that when I critique diet
or Wellness content or advice from a creator
online that Creator is probably not going to be
happy about it occasionally I get like a truly
gracious comment a response being like thank you
for educating me on this and explaining I had no
idea I will take it down Etc but more often
than not people are pissed especially people
with really big platforms who have a lot of
people watching and I get it a lot of these
Fringe diets become people's whole identity they
are so sure of the efficacy of something with zero
evidence to support it just based on their own
anecdotal experience or perhaps they're trying
to sell you something or both that their diet
is basically in their mind the only good diet
so when I come in there and point out the holes in
their absolute statements they feel they've been
personally attacked even if the criticism is not
personal at all but this response by Liz was just
so cowardly and below the belt to suggest that
just because I've struggled with mental health
that I can't educate intelligently on nutrition
really just demonstrates how little the world
understands about mental health you know it just
reinforces the common stereotype that those who
rely on medication to function optimally
are weak or unable to cope with hard times
Etc that they haven't just put in more time
to learn how to meditate or go on more walks
or cut out all the carbs Etc but this is an
example of pill shaming and it's actually one
of the strongest deterrents for people continuing
treatment for their mental health poppy needs more
emotional support than I do some days but yeah the
language used in this video was also remarkable
incredibly stigmatizing you know like to suggest
that I am dependent on psychiatric drugs to
function in the day or to sleep at night pains
those of us who use medication to support our
health as some kind of addicts I'm sorry but would
you shame someone with type 1 diabetes for being
dependent on their insulin pump to stay alive
would you shame someone with severe IBD for taking
steroids to help manage their debilitating flares
would you shame someone for going through chemo to
cure their cancer instead of like just cutting
out sugar I would hope not though as absurd as
that sounds I do see a lot of Fringe Wellness
anti-pharma Health coaches online take this
stance argue with me in the comments but I find it
remarkably unethical and dangerous when Healthcare
Providers allege that they can cure a chronic
disease purely through diet but that is a whole
other video for a whole other day here's the thing
every choice we make for our health comes with
some kind of price everything is a risk benefit
analysis sometimes the risk is financial sometimes
it's physical side effects sometimes it's like the
time in the gym or doing meal prep sometimes there
is a mental or a social price but even if I felt
like there was great data to support something
like a carnivore diet for depression and anxiety
which by the way there is absolutely not it would
need to be evaluated against the risk of being on
a carnivore diet we're talking about the physical
risk of lack of fiber and micronutrients
the financial risk of needing to take 32
supplements a day to make that up the social risk
of not being able to enjoy a meal with friends or
family more importantly at least for me the mental
risk of being dragged down into another Ed you
know I have basically accepted that I have some
underlying predispositions here that I will likely
never be able to just fully cure not through diet
not through therapy not through like prayer or
meditation not even through medication I now know
that my brain just kind of looks and functions
differently than neurotypical folks and I've got
strong perfectionistic tendencies that I will
probably never fully turn off and honestly I don't
want to like this is going to sound super cheesy
but I really love who I am this brain even though
it's certainly come with a lot of challenges my
life has pushed me to do some pretty cool thing
I am a great attentive involved mom I think I'm
really smart and great at the job despite whatever
results Liz fails to see and I'm the blue that
brings so many of my friends and family together
with all the constant party planning and events
everyone in my circle relies on me to do all of
these things and do them well because I do and
I'm proud of that so you know a lot of my outward
strengths are probably in a lot of ways related
to my internal struggle and Medicaid station has
allowed me to utilize my strengths much better
without as much of a personal burden to me Tick
Tock drama aside what I really want you to take
away from this is how damaging comments like this
can be especially coming from a creator with over
a million followers and never mind the damage that
it could potentially do to me to whom they were
actually directed but to all of the vulnerable
viewers watching who are struggling with the shame
of getting the help that they need you know the
lack of cultural conversation around mental health
and effective Mental Health Solutions is what
keeps stigma alive and thriving we have to talk
about this because talking about shame and stigma
takes its power away you know as researcher brene
Brown says shame cannot survive being spoken the
more influential people talk about their mental
health struggles and their medication use the
more open you know your neighbor or your workmate
or your friend will feel to open up about their
struggles and now once supportive non-judgmental
conversation may give someone the courage to seek
the help that they need to change their life and
this can have a very profound domino effect that
could quite literally change the world less stigma
would improve uptake of supportive Mental Health
Solutions which would prevent kind of an US versus
then mentally around the healthy and the mentally
ill which would decrease discrimination and
socio-economic disadvantage of getting a diagnosis
and support can we just take a moment to imagine
how much better we would all likely be doing if we
could make the best health choices for us without
fear of discrimination and retaliation standing
in our way so for the record I do not give a
if people want to pill shame me I'm not going
to stop taking my pills Irving me and I'm
all about taking my pills because I am privileged
to have a platform to do good and I am sure is
gonna use it while I still can and if you're
comfortable I would love if you would show
your support in the comments by sharing your
own mental health Journey even if it reaches
one other person who feels shame or fear around
getting the help that they need then I do feel
like we have done some important work here again
October 10th is mental health awareness day so I
really do encourage you to share this video on
your socials with your friends with your family
anyone who you feel could benefit from knowing
that they have your support and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it a thumbs up
do not forget to subscribe and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye Poppy
good work you support me I support you you
say girl these are some supportive sounds yep